vous souvenez vous des premiers mots que
vous allez entendu aujourd'hui
pythagore a dit le commencement et la
moitié de tous les hommes mangent trois
fois par jour depuis la nuit des temps
il y a le petit déjeuner le déjeuner et
le dîner
ah bah c'est pas de chance c'est faux
bon je vais pas en faire 50 non plus il
ya plein de manières différentes de
capter l'attention
il existe différentes techniques pour
intéresser une personne est ce que vous
allez lui dire est que ce soit dans les
interactions humaines dans un discours
où en plus spécifiquement dans une
dissertation vous devez accrocher la
personne à laquelle vous vous adressez à
quoi est-ce que ça sert une accroche une
amorce en dissertation ça c'est à
intéresser le correcteur bien sûr il
vous lira de toute façon puisqu'il est
payé pour
mais il sera mieux disposée à votre
égard si vous réussissez votre accroche
vous avez donc intérêt à la soigner je
sais que certains profs recommande de ne
pas faire d' accroche
moi je ne suis pas d'accord mais ce
conseil n'est pas stupide parce qu'il
est difficile de rédiger une bonne
accroche
enfin c'est difficile pour tous ceux qui
n'auront pas vu cette vidéo
mais si vous regardez cette vidéo
jusqu'à la fin ça sera bien moins
difficile
en fait tout sera difficile en
dissertation pour ceux qui ne se seront
pas préparé avec mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation
inscrivez vous donc pour le recevoir
le lien doit s'afficher maintenant en
haut à droite mais vous pouvez aussi
trouver le lien dans la description de
la vidéo c'est un cours par e-mail donc
vous pouvez d'abord regarder cette vidéo
entièrement puis vous découvrirez mes
techniques de méthodologie juste après
vous bien dans les prochains jours
maintenant j'ai une question pour vous
pourquoi est-ce que vous devez rédiger
une accroche parce que dans
l'introduction de la dissertation après
la croche
il ya la définition des termes et que
donc si vous ne faites pas la croche et
bien la première chose
je lis le correcteur c'est la définition
des termes c'est à dire le passage le
plus chiant de la dissertation
c'est comme si la première chose que je
vous disais c'est ce qu'il ya sur ma
carte d'identité en main très faible né
en france j'ai eu marc aumont et c'est
ça donne pas envie
alors c'est vrai que si vous n'avez
vraiment aucune idée pour la croche il
vaut peut être mieux ne pas faire d'
accroche plutôt que de faire mauvaise
impression dès le début de la
dissertation avec une accroche
maladroite mais si vous avez bien
préparer votre épreuve de dissertation
si vous avez regardé cette vidéo
jusqu'au bout il n'y a pas de raison
vous saurez rédiger une bonne accroche
j'ai maintenant vous révéler les cinq
types d'akreuch possible en dissertation
rester jusqu'à la fin parce qu'à mon
avis vous ne connaissez pas les 5e et il
va vous étonner
[Musique]
le premier type d'accrochage possible et
le plus courant c'est d'introduire une
référence comme vous le feriez dans un
paragraphe du développement de votre
dissertation cette accroche sert à
capter l'attention du correcteur en
évoquant une idée intéressante et en
invoquant l' autorité intellectuelle
d'un auteur alors il faut bien sûr que
l'idée soit à la fois pertinente c'est à
dire qu'elles soient bien en rapport
avec l'énoncé et il faut aussi qu'elle
soit intéressante comme j'ai déjà dit je
vous donne un exemple j'ai commencé ma
dissertation sur le sujet philosopher s
apprendre à mourir par la phrase
suivante dans son histoire de la
philosophie julian mariage considère que
seule la métaphysique mérite le nom de
philosophie là à grosso modo jeudi qu'un
historien de la philosophie répondrais
non à la question de l'énoncé d'après
julian maria cela philosophie ce n'est
pas apprendre à mourir mais découvrir la
vérité sur notre monde on accroche et
bien sûr pertinente puisque c'est une
réponse à la question dénoncé elle est
aussi intéressante parce que c'est une
référence plutôt original est aussi un
point de vue tranché
une fois que vous avez présenté la
référence avec une phrase clair
vous devez encore approfondi à l'idée
sur une ou deux phrases si son rapport
avec les anciennes n'est pas évident
vous devez les expliquer davantage allez
on passe au deuxième type dha croche le
deuxième type dha croche qui le plus
classe entre guillemets c'est de citer
un auteur vous souvenez d'une formule en
rapport avec les non c est bien vous
commencez votre dissertation par cette
forme et comme pour le premier type dha
croche
il faut bien sûr que l'idée de la
citation souhaite à la fois pertinentes
et intéressantes
ça c'est important parce que je sais que
les élèves aiment bien écrire des
citations parce qu'il pense que ça va
impressionner le correcteur mais la
plupart du temps la citation n'est pas
très pertinentes
donc elle ne produit pas un bon effet
conclusion ne cherchait pas à tout prix
à cazères une citation choisie c'est ce
type d'accord uniquement si lille et
vous semble évidemment pertinente par
rapport à l'énoncé je vous donne un
exemple j'aurais pu commencer ma
dissertation sur le sujet philosopher
c'est apprendre à mourir par cette
citation des lettres à lucilius de
sénèque savoir mourir et la seule chose
qu un jour on exigera forcément de nous
l'idée pertinente parce qu'elle traite
de la mort et parce que sénèque est un
philosophe et elle est aussi
intéressante parce qu'elle est un peu
radical sénéque dit que savoir bruire
est la seule chose on exigera de nous
comme pour le premier type dha croche
vous devez encore développé l'idée
surtout nos phrases allez on continue
type d'across numéro 3
[Musique]
troisième type dha croche et peut-être
le plus accrocheur c'est raconter une
anecdote
bah oui c'est accrocheur parce que les
hommes adorent les histoires bien sûr la
croche doit toujours être pertinente
mais une bonne anecdote ça implique plus
particulièrement deux choses ce que vous
racontez doit être un minimum curieux
c'est à dire que ça doit étonner le
correcteur pour le dire plus simplement
l'histoire ne doit pas être banal et la
seconde chose c'est que vous devez
raconter quelque chose de précis donc
pas de tout temps ou dans l'histoire
humaine
au contraire vous devez raconté que
telle personne a fait telle chose à
telle époque je vais vous donner un
exemple sur le sujet philosopher s
apprendre à mourir
ça serait peut-être difficile pour un
étudiant de trouver une anecdote
pertinentes sur ce sujet mais j'ai une
idée je peux raconter avec quelle
sérénité secrète a bu le poison lors de
l'exécution de sa peine de mort voici
comment je commencerai ma dissertation
avec cette anecdote lorsque le gardien
chef de la prison a signalé que le
moment était venu
socrates n'a pas hésité il a pris la
coupe et il a bu la ciguë sans trembler
cette confiance dans le passage à l'acte
laisse à penser qu'il était prêt à
mourir
en général vous aurez besoin de deux
trois phrases pour présenter une
anecdote parce que ce n'est pas
simplement une idée et comment les types
d'across précédent là vous avez besoin
de raconter un fait il y a plusieurs
actions à décrire donc ça sera
probablement plus clair avec plusieurs
phrases ce type d'accrocher certes plus
accrocheur mais il demande aussi une
plus grande culture générale
allez on passe au quatrième type dha
croche
[Musique]
le quatrième type dha croche possible en
dissertation c'est d'invoquer un fait
d'actualité récents le principe de ce
type d'accrochage c'est de capter
l'attention du lecteur en lui montrant
que le problème dont il est question
dans la dissertation est toujours
d'actualité ce qui implique qu'en lisant
la dissertation il pourra mieux
comprendre le monde dans lequel il vit
c'est la connexion que vous opérez entre
le présent concret et le monde des idées
c'est cette connexion qui permet de
capter l'attention du lecteur alors je
vais vous donner un exemple tout de
suite pour que vous compreniez ce que je
veux dire par fait d'actualité récente
sur le sujet à philosopher c'est
apprendre à mourir
ça serait trop difficile et par
conséquent trop risqué
donc je vais choisir un autre sujet
voici comment je commencerai une
dissertation sur le sujet travailler
moins s vivre mieux le confinement de
2020 a entraîné de nombreux français à
interroger le sens de leur activité
professionnelle
cette accroche montre aux correcteurs
que la question du lien entre le travail
et le bonheur est très actuelle une
seule phrase ça serait un peu court donc
j'expliquerai encore l'actualité de la
question sur une ou deux phrases
alors ce type d'accrocher plutôt
accrocheur lui aussi mais il présente
deux risques le premier c'est le risque
de la vulgarité
il ne faut pas que le fait d'actualité
que vous présentez donne l'impression
que vous retenez uniquement les
informations superficielles et que vous
êtes incapable d'aller en profondeur par
exemple il ne faut pas évoqué en
accroche un scandale politique récent où
une petite phrase qui aurait dit un
homme politique et qui est dans tous les
esprits pendant une semaine
ce qu'il faut c'est que le correcteur
puisse comprendre facilement que le
'fait d'actualité' illustres ou révèle
une question profonde
le second risque de ce type d'accrochage
c'est le parti pris en présentant le
fait d'actualité
vous ne devez pas dire du mal ou dire du
bien d'une action d'une parole d'une
personne d'une idée
etc vous devez rester le plus neutre
possible
vous devez rester factuel un peu comme
un journaliste même si vous êtes un être
humain et même si l'objectivité n'existe
pas l'idéal c'est de présenter un fait
avéré en dépouillant votre description
de toute interprétation ce type
d'accrochage peut sembler facile parce
qu'on vit dans un monde où l'information
est surabondante
mais vous l'avez compris sélectionnés et
présentés un fait d'actualité pour en
faire une bonne accroche de dissertation
ce n'est pas facile
allez on passe au 5e et dernier type dha
croche le cinquième type d'accrochage
possible en dissertation c'est de donner
un chiffre ou une statistique ciboule ce
type d'accord est particulièrement
accrocheur parce que les données
chiffrées porte en elle l'autorité de la
science
autrement dit quand on lit une
statistique on a l'impression que c'est
la vérité vraie bien sûr la statistique
peut être fausse ou ne pas vouloir dire
grand chose elle re sujette à
interprétation mais en général nous
tombons dans le piège parce que nous
sommes très sensibles à l'autorité
intellectuelle qui émane des chiffres et
c'est pour ça que nous aimons les
statistiques
alors je ne vous dis pas d'inventer des
chiffres pour séduire le correcteur je
ne vous dis pas non plus que toutes les
statistiques ne valent rien au contraire
moi j'aime bien donner des chiffres en
accroche
je trouve ça intéressant et original
mais si vous voulez le faire
sérieusement vous devez respecter deux
conditions
en plus de la pertinence nation voici
les deux conditions
votre statistiques doit être précise et
sources et je vous montre comment faire
avec un exemple voici comment je pourrai
commencer une dissertation sur le sujet
travailler moins et vivre mieux
d'après un sondage ifop de 2016 75 % des
français se disent heureux au travail
ma statistique et précise je n'ai pas
écrit une majorité de français j'ai
donné le chiffre exact du sondage
ma statistique est également source et
j'ai donné le nom de l'institut de
sondage qui a produit l'étude et j'ai
précisé l'année de l'étude
mais si je commence ma dissertation en
écrivant d'après les sondages plus de la
moitié des français
sont heureux au travail là c'est trop
imprécis ça passerait probablement au
bac mais bon tout passe au bac ça
passerait certainement au bac mais un
correcteur de concours ne s'en
satisferaient pas il veut un résultat
précis il veut savoir d'où vient ce
résultat précis ce sont ces exigences
qui rendent ce dernier type dha croche
plus difficile à rédiger que les autres
[Musique]
en résumé vous pouvez utiliser cinq
types d'across en dissertation vous
pouvez introduire une référence que vous
feriez dans un par ailleurs du
développement vous pouvez écrire une
citation raconter une anecdote fait
d'actualité et enfin vous pouvez donner
une statistique je vous recommande de
privilégier les trois premiers types
d'across parce que les deux derniers le
fait d'actualité et la statistique
ces deux types d'across sont plus
difficiles à rédiger souvenez vous aussi
que votre accroche doit toujours être
pertinente et relativement précise
voulait tester des accroches et bien
écrivait dans les commentaires et je
vous dirai ce que j'en pense après
n'accordez pas trop d'importance à la
croche
parce que ce n'est pas essentiel pour
réussir une dissertation ce qu'il vous
faut pour réussir vos dissertation c'est
une méthodologie solide
je vous invite donc à vous inscrire pour
recevoir mon cours gratuits de
méthodologie de la dissertation soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette
vidéo
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu et puisqu'elle vous sera
utile
je suis en main que je suis toujours
avec mon fidèle aristote et vous étiez
sur mille idées de culture générale
rappelez vous que vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour réussir les
accroche le mot dissertation
[Musique]